-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Oh, right,
you don't want me to ask.
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday
called on China
to participate in a, "full
transparent, evidence-based,
internal investigation to find
the origins of COVID-19."
Said China,
"Honestly, can this wait?
We are just slammed
with COVID-21.
Or, I mean, sure, no problem."
That's right, President Bide
called on China to participate
in an investigation to fin
the origins of COVID-19,
and I just got to say,
if it's not bats,
we owe them a major apology.
It's going to be like one of
those double jeopardy scenario
where they've been wrongfull
blamed for a crime,
so now they really do
get to start a pandemic.
According to a new report,
former president Trump
tried to intervene in 2008
to stop the investigation
of the New England Patriots'
so-called "Spygate" scandal.
Wait, he was involved
in that scandal, too?
He's like the Forrest Gump
of scandals.
Next, we're going to find out he
was one of the 1919 Black Sox.
British prime Minister Boris
Johnson reportedly considere
getting the coronavirus
injected in his body
on live TV last summer
because he thought the virus
wasn't a threat.
Who are you, Prime Ministe
Johnny Knoxville?
Boris Johnson's
the only U.K. leader
to come with
his own theme music.
[ "Jackass" theme song playing ]
[ Laughter ]
The Recording Academy yesterda
announced changes to the Gramm
Awards' nomination process
That's right --
You can now be nominated
if you're Taylor Swift
or Beyoncé.
Today was Republican Congressman
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
47th birthday, which is also
the only accurate informatio
on her Facebook page.
That's right, today was
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
47th birthday.
And if you're wondering
what to get her, how about help?
And that was a monologue,
everybody.